jennifer lopez is opening up about a
scary time in her life when she says she
had a panic attack and felt paralyzed in
her latest on the jlo newsletter the
marry me actress recalls the crippling
experience she writes she thought she
was invincible in her late 20s when she
used to get just three to five hours of
sleep a night as her career was
skyrocketing releasing music like her
debut single
[Music]
and movies like 1998's out of sight
opposite george clooney let's get out of
here
jlo explains that one day she was
sitting in a trailer when she completely
froze work was an all-consuming priority
and she let her self-care needs go
completely quote i found myself feeling
physically paralyzed i couldn't see
clearly and then the physical symptoms i
was having started to scare me and the
fear compounded itself as for how she
recovered jen recalls her security guard
picking her up from the trailer and
driving her to a doctor jen told the doc
she thought she was losing her mind and
he told her she needed to make a big
lifestyle change sleep seven to nine
hours a night no caffeine and plenty of
exercise that's when jennifer decided to
prioritize living a healthy and balanced
life you gotta you know live right you
know you eat right and you work out you
know nobody can escape the hard work
that it takes to get results on anything
in life you all of us have to work hard
at it and i definitely do jen says her
philosophy is more pro-living instead of
anti-aging she lifts weights three to
four days a week and does cardio when
she's trying to shed a few extra pounds
physically you know you want to be in
good shape and when it comes to diet jen
is all about moderation here's a pic of
her typical dinner which includes a
balance of healthy dishes she says the
bread and fries are for her twins 14
year old emmy and max although she
admits to picking at those sometimes too
based on the new pics she shared with
her kids and fiance ben affleck jennifer
seems to be glowing from the inside out
i'm
super excited just last month the triple
threat shared this sweet father's day
tribute to ben
this is the best time of my life i love
my career but nothing is more fulfilling
to me than being able to build a family
with someone who i love deeply and who
is just as dedicated to family and and
to each other as we can be and uh i'm
just i feel incredibly blessed of course
the couple got engaged again in april
after previously being engaged from 2002
to 2004. shortly after ben popped the
question the second time around jen
shared these intimate details it was
totally unexpected
my love came in ben came in and he got
down on one knee
and he said some things that i'll never
forget
and then he pulled out a ring
and he said will you marry me
and it was
the most perfect moment as for when
they'll head down the aisle well a
source told e.t and may that they want
to get married soon and are leaning
toward a destination or tropical wedding
the source adds they can't wait to spend
the rest of their lives together forever
happily in love
you